herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
will heute zeige ich euch endlich wie
man macarons macht das hat mich wirklich
stunden gekostet dieses rezept für euch
zu machen
ich habe wirklich schon öfter versucht
man kann auch selbst zu stellen
aber irgendwie hat man doch nicht
geklappt die oberfläche war nicht klar
die magirus sind eingerissen und alles
zusammen und jetzt habe ich mich mal
hingesetzt habe auch viel im internet
recherchiert und habs jetzt einfach mal
ausprobiert ich habe einfach die ganzen
anweisungen befolgt dann mal nicht
befolgt als ich habe alles zusammen
geschmissen und im endeffekt kam es
dieses rezept dabei raus die macarons in
mit sehr gut dabei gelungen und ich habe
jetzt noch zwei versionen für euch
nämlich einmal die komplett selbst
gemachte version in der man eben sein
wandel mail selbst herstellen muss und
einmal die version mit einem starter kit
das gibt's bei mir im shop und ich sage
ich es einfach mal beide versionen ich
bin nämlich beide gut ich hab die
macarons in zwei geschmacksrichtungen
gemacht die selbstgemachten macarons
habe ich in orangener chaos verwandelt
und die mit dem startpaket habe ich als
schoko macarons verfeinert und ich zeige
ich es erst einmal wie man die orangen
mache ausmacht und später dann wenn man
die show komax ausmacht
für die macarons braucht ihr mandeln da
habe ich jetzt gehabt der mann drogen
genommen weil die einfach schon gestellt
sind und nicht so keine mantel zählen
muss ihr braucht nämlich mandeln ohne
schale und da habe ich jetzt 45 gramm
ich habe 65 gramm puderzucker zehn gramm
zucker eine prise salz und jetzt braucht
ihr noch einmal und zwar 35 gramm
und da wir es einfach ein eiweiß
reingeschlagen und wenn ihr jetzt ein zu
großes eiweiß habt könnt ihr das so
machen mainz weg den 37 kam dann nehme
ich mir einfach mit einer spritze den
überschuss weg und kann das so richtig
genau dosieren
also sollte es zwischen 30 und 35 km
haben aber nicht mehr weil alle
die masse viel zu weich wird das
wichtigste ist jetzt dass er jetzt diese
mandeln richtig fein bekommt also so
richtig feine puder und das mache ich
jetzt in meinem thermomix das könnt ihr
aber natürlich in jeder antwort
küchenmaschine auch machen die eben
leistungsstarker das habe ich hier eben
schon gemacht deswegen sitzt das jetzt
auch so aus und zwar gebe ich jetzt die
mandeln da rein und gibt da noch den
puderzucker mitte zu weil die mandeln
alleine niemals so fein gewerken deckel
drauf und das ganze jetzt einfach auf
höchster stufe
so sieht das ganze dann aus und das
solltet ihr so etwa 2-3 mal machen bis
es richtig schön fallen ist und jetzt
müsst ihr dieses mangel bruder was er
schon sehr fein ist aber auch noch mal
durch so ein feines sieb streichen
einfach um zu verhindern dass da noch so
großes stückchen mit rein kommen
das muss nämlich richtig schön fein sein
damit später die oberfläche der macarons
auch richtig glatt wird das mandelmilch
spielt beim einfach eine ganz wichtige
rolle
deswegen müsst ihr das auch wirklich mit
einer leistungsstarken küchenmaschine
zerkleinern und ob das ist dann der
thermomix ist oder irgendein anderer
standmixer ist wirklich egal hauptsache
er ist der leistungsstark und es müsst
ihr wirklicher 456 machen ist dieses mal
ging mir richtig frei ist wie normales
mail und glöckchen frei dann könnt ihr
es nämlich verwenden und dann bekommt
die auch ein perfektes ergebnis so sieht
dann jetzt mal mandl will aus also
richtig schön fein und richtig pulver
artig und jetzt muss ich mich um das
eiweiß kümmern
das gebe ich jetzt in meiner
küchenmaschine das kann man natürlich
auch mit einem handrührgerät machen
da kommt meine prise salz mit dazu und
das passt jetzt bei höchster stufe steif
schlagen und gibt dann nach und nach dem
kristallzucker mit dazu bis es eine
richtig schöne steife besemer 6
und jetzt gebe ich zu dieser bc masse
direkt noch meine passten farbe mit dazu
ihr solltet da unbedingt passend farbe
benutzen weil das einfach die
konsistenzen verändert ich nämlich den
orangen geht mitten und sauberen messer
reihen
das gebe ich hiermit dazu die bse massig
fertig wenn sie richtig schön in form
bleibt und steif steht dann könnte
nämlich die küchenmaschine zurzeit
erstellen
die brauchte dann nicht mehr jetzt wird
die mandel masse hier noch untergehoben
ganz vorsichtig das mache ich jetzt in
zwei schritten und zwar solltet ihr
jetzt so wenig luft wie möglich aus
dieser bc masse heraus schlagen
und deswegen ist es auch ganz wichtig
die farbe vorher schon dazu zu geben
da wird man jetzt eben nicht mehr lange
röhren muss und so sollte dann die
konsistenz des teigs sein also schon
eher noch ein festerer teig den teig
gebe ich dann in den spritzbeutel ich
benutze einen einweg spritzbeutel weil
ich den song danach einfach wegschmeißen
kann dann scheide ich da oben einfach
eine spitze ab so etwa ein zentimeter
und jetzt spritzig kreise auf das
backblech so etwa in der größe von zwei
euro stück
so sieht das ganze dann bei mir aus also
man hat auch ruhig 20 machen können ich
habe zu 19 macarons gespritzt jetzt habe
ich das blech an und lass es auf die
arbeitsfläche fallen so kommen nämlich
die luftbläschen raus und kommen später
nicht unschön an die oberfläche jetzt
habe ich euch gezeigt wie man die man
kameras aufwändig selbst herstellen kann
und zeigt euch jetzt wie man sie mit dem
staat machen kann
ich will dieses staates wirklich sehr
gut weil es einfach alles beinhaltet was
man braucht und man braucht echt nur
ganz kurz zeit dafür
und vor allen dingen für die leute die
eben keine küchenmaschine haben
und eben dieses mandl nicht so sein
zerkleinern können ist es eben perfekt
geeignet weil es wirklich ein wichtiges
kriterium dafür ist ob eure macarons
eben letztendlich gelingen oder nicht
ich werde die mitgelieferten farben
jetzt nicht verwenden weil die schoko
macarons draus machen und etwas
kakaopulver einarbeiten und wie ich das
mache das sei jetzt dass das sieht so
aus das bekommt ihr dann in so einem
karton und da ist damit drin einmal
diese backmischung also da ist dieses
eiweißpulver drin puderzucker und mandel
mail dass es ganz fein gemahlen und es
sind 250 gramm und da müsst ihr später
dann nur wasser hinzufügen
dann sind da zwei lebensmittelfarben
drinnen einmal grün einmal rot die sind
flüssig für die macarons sind sie ganz
gut denn diese mischung ist so dass man
da etwas weniger wasser dazu gibt es
eine sehr feste masse und durch diese
farben bekommt dann die richtige
konsistenz und dann sind da noch den
einweg spritzbeutel mit dabei die sind
ja immer sehr praktisch und das ganze
gibt's aber auch nur als fertige
mischung fertige backmischungen da ist
dann eine 500 gramm makro mischung mit
dabei und die spritz tüten und die
farben sind nicht dabei das heißt wer
schon farben und spritzt tüten besitzt
kann sich einfach diese fertige mandl
mail mischung nehmen das ist nämlich
sehr praktisch weil er eben metal ist
und weil es ganz
einfach die makro herstellung sehr
vereinfacht wie die das mit der
backmischung machen wollt dann nehmt ihr
einfach die backmischung das netz 250
gramm und 45 milliliter wasser und weil
ich da jetzt schoko macarons draus
machen möchte nämlich noch einen
teelöffel kakaopulver also ohne zucker
diesen ganz normalen kakaopulver und
weil es etwas trockener ist habe ich
jetzt hier noch zusätzlich fünf
milliliter wasser genommen
also habe ich hier insgesamt 50 diese
fertige mischung ist schön fein aber ich
geb dir trotzdem durch den sieg einfach
um sicherzugehen dass wirklich keine
klümpchen drin vorkommen
und da gebe ich auch gleich das
kakaopulver mit rein wenn es dann soweit
habt zieht es in etwa so aus
und da gebe ich jetzt das wasser noch
mit dazu und dann muss das ganze drei
minuten bei höchster stufe verrührt
werden das geht mit einer küchenmaschine
aber genauso gut auch mit einem
handrührgerät
und hier zeige ich euch mal wie sich das
ganze befüllen lässt wenn man eben
sondern ein weg spritzbeutel mit adapter
und lochte benutzt ich habe jetzt hier
in der lochmühle mit 12 mm und dann kann
ich das einfach wir rein 7
und so kann man das ganze eigentlich da
vorne eben besser halten und hat eben
mehr halt um das dann auch die folie zu
spritzen
und hier jetzt eben genau das gleiche
was spitze ich mir kleine kreise auch
mein blech
die macarons müssen jetzt wollen banken
noch 40 minuten einfach an der
oberfläche etwas antrocknen dafür lasse
es einfach im zimmer stehen und laster
in der zeit einfach die oberfläche
antrocknen das war nämlich mein problem
dass ich immer zu puls und damals so
lange habt stehen lassen und dann reißt
eben die oberfläche ein
also diese zeit müsst ihr ex dad durch
abwarten und dann wird er danach richtig
perfekte macarons gekommen
ich habe auch schon probiert die bei
umluft zu backen und bei ober und
unterhitze und jetzt nicht gedacht aber
bei ober und unterhitze werden sie
wirklich perfekt bei umluft sind sie mir
leider nicht gelungen
keine ahnung wieso aber bei ober und
unterhitze bei 150 grad habe ich sie 15
minuten gebacken das kann natürlich je
nach oben variieren aber so zwischen 14
und 16 minuten sollten sie in etwa
backen und ich sage ich jetzt einfach
mal wie sie vor dem backen ausgesehen
haben und dann wie sie ihm der name
ausgesehen haben
so sehen jetzt die fertigen macarons aus
und die sind jetzt wirklich echt perfekt
geworden
ich zeige euch mal zum vergleich die die
leider risse bekommen haben und zwar sah
es so aus als im grunde auch marco russ
geworden aber oben eben da riss oder
hier diese hier hatte ich auch nicht
warten lassen
und damit ich jetzt auch das andere
blech backen kann nämlich dass ross und
sie ganz einfach die folie und dann
können die macarons hier abkühlen und
ich kann die andere folie hier drauf
ziehen als füllung nehme ich jetzt
einfach eine orangen füllung und auf die
idee kam ich weil ich ja ganz gerne
lernen können und habe das jetzt einfach
etwas abgewandelt in die orangen version
und ohne ei sondern mit speisestärke ihr
könnt diese rezepte ab natürlich
abwandeln und stadt orange könnt ihr
auch zitrone neben oder eben andere
säfte und wie ich das jetzt mache zeige
ich euch jetzt einfach mal wird die
creme nämlich eine orange die es
unbehandelt
ich nehme 30 gramm zucker 15km stärke
und 50 gramm butter und von der orange
werde ich jetzt die orangenschale
benutzen deswegen solltet ihr auch
unbehandelt sein
jetzt nehme ich mir hier einfach einen
kleinen topf und gibt da schon mal die
euro schule rein
anbieter der orangensaft reingepresst
und das sollten dann etwa 125 dran sein
und da müsste dann falls nötig mit
wasser auffüllen oder mit etwas
zitronensaft und dann kommt da jetzt die
stärke mit rein und auch der zucker und
dann wird es jetzt einmal verrührt und
aufgekocht
wenn das ganze dann ein mal aufgekocht
hat ist es auch schon richtig eingedeckt
und da könnt ihr dann die butter mieter
zugegeben
sie löst sich schon war schön auf da
könnte den helfern auch abschalten
die restwärme reicht dafür die creme
fühle ich dann in ein kleines schildchen
um und kann sie dann in den kühlschrank
geben
und wenn sie dann wieder kalt ich schon
die mutter fest ist dann kann man sie in
die macarons reihen spritzen wenn
orangen creme die habe ich jetzt hier in
schüssel gegeben und schlagt sie ganz
kurz auf das mache ich es einfach mit
dem handrührgerät
und dann habe ich mir die creme ist
einfach in einen spritzbeutel gefüllt
mit einer lok schüler und kann jetzt die
macarons damit würfel einfach ein
bisschen in die mitte und dann legt dann
den zweiten obendrauf und drückt ganz
ganz vorsichtig zusammen
und so sehen jetzt übrigens die schoko
macarons aus also die sehen optisch sehr
viel anders aus die haben auch da unten
nicht diese füßchen aber eben eine
richtig schöne glatte oberfläche meine
show macarons werde ich jetzt mit etwas
nur teller füllen
aber wer es gerne etwas schokoladiger
und herr mag kann natürlich auch eine
gans zum beispiel herstellen
mit etwas zarter schokolade oder anderen
schokoladensorten und da könnt ihr
wirklich die macarons befüllen mit was
ihr möchtet ihr könnt auch einfach mal
laden nehmen oder eben andere butter
krems und könnt die nach eurer fantasie
und nach eurem geschmack eben befüllen
hier habe ich jetzt noch die mit
schokolade und da habe ich jetzt einfach
ein bisschen nutella in meinen
spritzbeutel gegeben und gibt es nur
teller einfach hier in die mitte dann
kommt da wieder der deckel drauf und
durch so leichte kreisende bewegungen
könnt ihr das auch rein drehen oder dass
es beschädigt wird ihr habt jetzt von
mir beide versionen gesehen einmal die
selbstgemachten macarons und einmal die
macarons mit dem starter kit und ihr
könnt euch selbst entscheiden welche
version ihr bevorzugt ich fand der
zweite sei gut allerdings waren wir die
erste version etwas zu zeitintensiv
ich dachte eigentlich dass man kann's
nicht so sehr mein fall sind weil sie so
süß sind aber letztendlich muss ich
sagen auch gerade mit dieser orange mit
dem nutella hat mich wirklich sehr gut
geschmeckt weil man kann da nicht 56
davon essen aber so 2 von jeder sorte
gehen auf jeden fall und ich zeige ich
auch nochmal mit ihm akkus von innen
aussehen und zwar sollten makler raus
außenrum diese schöne kruste haben und
ihnen sind so richtig schön feucht und
flippig und bei den schocker macarons
ist natürlich genauso ich hoffe meine
tipps helfen euch zweiter und ihr
bekommt auch die perfekten macarons hin
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall viel
spaß dabei wenn es euch auch so gut geht
postet mir ein foto auf meine band und
ich freue mich schon drauf und ich
wünsche euch noch eine ganz schöne zeit
bis dahin das rezept findet ihr auf
meinem blog auf www q-cells torten
welt.de schaut da einfach mal rein und
dann sehen wir schon bald wieder